وعشرين مليون دولار دخل فيلم سبايدر مان
اكروس ذيس
عالم الارقام القياسيه محققا اكثر من
ثلاثه اضعاف الجزء الاول لهذه السلسله من
الرسوم المتحركه الفيلم الجديد حصل على
تقييم رائع بلغ بلغ طبعا هذه التقييمات
95% ليتجاوز توقعات شركه
المنتجه له بعد عرضه في امريكا وكندا
اعمال الرسوم المتحركه تحقيقا للارباح في
اسبوع الاسبوع الاول هذا العام بعد فيلم
سوبر ماريو يوسع الجزء الجديد مفهوم
الاكوان بشكل اكبر كانت التوقعات تشير
لتحقيق 80 مليون دولار كارباح بعد ان كلف
100 مليون دولار
متابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات